Movie fans never know just how much time,
money and energy is spent creating the next
Hollywood hit before cameras ever start rolling.
But as polished or acclaimed as a script may
be, there’s no predicting what will happen
when the cast and crew arrive on set.
And sometimes, lines or scenes improvised
on the spot can not only work, but become
instant classics.
Here are Screen Rant's 10 Amazing Movie Scenes
That Were Completely Improvised.
The Avengers: Age of Ultron
Even though the two met as enemies, Hawkeye
and Quicksilver wound up as allies by the
movie's final fight.
But that didn't stop the archer from being
tempted to take him down.
The gag was improvised by Jeremy Renner during
shooting, and was just too good to leave out.
Guardians of the Galaxy
Bradley Cooper recorded the voice for Rocket
Raccoon once filming had wrapped, but it was
director James Gunn's brother Sean who played
the mercenary on set.
When the rest of the team are agreeing to
lead a suicide mission, the actor apparently
had his co-stars in tears - before improvising
the now famous end to the entire scene.
Independence Day
Sometimes, an unscripted line can fit the
scene so perfectly, audiences never even think
to catch it.
When Will Smith's fighter pilot is dragging
an unconscious alien across the salt flats,
he lets all his frustration out on his would-be
killer.
Nobody warned the crew that Utah's Great Salt
Lake is home to millions of brine shrimp,
who rot just below the sandy crust when the
lake dries out.
The result: Will Smith's final outburst had
nothing to do with the alien - just the location.
Jurassic World
As serious as a runaway dinosaur might be,
the Jurassic Park sequel found time for plenty
of humor.
But when the oddball tech Lowery decides to
play the hero (the footage leading up to everyone
else leaving the island, and him staying behind
to help the heroes), he gets shut down fast.
The line was improvised, and the two playing
out the surprise reveal made it into the final
cut.
The LEGO Movie
Given how famous Morgan Freeman's voice has
become, it shouldn't surprise us that even
his outtakes are too good to leave out.
When Vitruvius is introducing Emmet to the
rest of the Master Builders, a mix-up with
Gandalf and Dumbledore leads to a quick one-liner.
The line wasn't performed, but actually spoken
by Freeman to the directors during his time
in the recording booth.
Obviously, the directors found the perfect
place to fit in the glimpse of Freeman's sense
of humor.
The Wolf of Wall Street
Matthew McConaughey has become famous for
doing everything a little bit differently,
but sometimes, his odd behavior behind the
camera makes it in front.
When audiences first saw his character start
humming and beating his chest in a crowded
restaurant, they were just as confused as
Leonardo DiCaprio.
The ritual was one McConaughey would actually
practice before shoots.
When his co-star caught it, he asked if they
could try it during the scene.
Even so, you can spot DiCaprio cracking up,
and even looking to his director and crew
as the ritual builds.
Star Trek
The big screen reboot of Star Trek managed
to excite a new generation of moviegoers,
while doing right by fans of the original
- and Leonard Nimoy's appearance as the original
Spock was a big part of it.
As proof that the classics are to be trusted,
Nimoy asked J.J. Abrams if he could improvise
his final line after seeing Kirk given command
of the Enterprise.
It was a perfect moment, sending the movie
towards its close, and letting Spock - and
Nimoy - hand the franchise off to a new generation
with a single order.
True Lies
James Cameron's big-budget spy thriller had
a ton of stunts, but it was Jamie Lee Curtis'
relentless workout plan that made headlines,
insisting that she perform a sultry dance
for her on-screen husband personally.
She got just as carried away as her character,
apparently, since her fall to the floor was
completely unscripted - you can even watch
as Arnold Schwarzenegger jumps up to help
before realizing she's pushing through, and
sliding back into the scene as best he can
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
Fans didn't have high hopes for the movie
reboot of the heroes in the half-shell, but
the modern Ninja Turtles kept the teenage
energy completely intact.
Some of that is due to the actual actors playing
the part.
When the producer noticed the stars goofing
around and free-styling between takes, he
insisted they do the same for the actual movie.
It became one of the best scenes in the movie,
with the animators turning the improvised
song into a CG masterpiece.
Captain America
Marvel relied on some risky special effects
to bring their star soldier to life prior
to his superhero rebirth.
But even if star Chris Evans was added onto
a smaller actor to start, the audience couldn't
prepare themselves for the musclebound super-soldier
that emerged - and neither could Evans' co-star,
Hayley Atwell.
The actress has admitted that she's genuinely
flustered in the scene, with her reactions,
and the need to actually touch Evans' pecs
all completely unscripted.
Can you blame her?
Those are the famous, iconic, or hilarious
movie moments that have luck and improv to
thank, but what favorites of yours have we
missed?
Let us know in the comments, and subscribe
to our channel so you don't miss our next
installment!